من نجا من فك الزلزال به وبمنزله قد لا
ينجو من كارثه صحيه تتربص به الكوليرا عدو
اخر يهدد سوريا وتركيا
ناقوس الخطر دقته منظمه اليونيسف التي
حذرت من مخاطر انتشار واسع للامراض
المنقوله بواسطه المياه حيث تبقى مخاطر
الاصابه بامراض مثل الكوليرا
والاسهالتاريا في اعلى مستوياتها على
الاطلاق في اعقاب كارثه الزلزال في سوريا
تم اعلان تفشي الكوليرا قبل خمسه اشهر في
عقب الزلزال ربما تكون مصادر المياه
النظيفه القليل المتاحه قد تضررت ايضا
قلق عالمي يتزايد اذا انتشار وباء
الكوليرا الذي ظهر مجددا في سوريا
والارقام تحكي عن رصد 84 الف حاله كوليرا
منذ سبتمبر الماضي حتى بدايه هذا العام
المعطيات وفق المنظمات الصحيه تشير الى
ازدياد الحالات ان لم تتم معالجه الشبكات
المتضرره بالسرعه الممكنه
الحال نفسها في تركيا وان كانت بدرجات اقل
المياه غمرت شوارع بعض المناطق المتضرره
من الزلزال
وسط تقارير غربيه تشير الى نقص حاد في
المياه الصالحه للشرب في تلك المناطق
الامر الذي يضاعف الخسائر وينذر بكارثه
صحيه اخرى قبل الاستفاقه من صدمه الكارثه
الزلزال